دعت ام الطفله الفلسطينيه هند رجب في
مقابله مع الجزيره المؤسسات والمنظمات
الدوليه للتحرك من اجل البحث عن ابنتها
المفقوده منذ اسبوع والكشف عن مصيرها يذكر
ان ام الطفلتين هند وليان قد افادت في
مقابله سابقه مع الجزيره باستشهاد ابنتها
ليان فيما اختفت ابنتها الثانيه هند وطاقم
فريق اسعاف تابع للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
بعدما حاصرته ما قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
قرب محط للمحروقات في مدينه
غزه انا اسمي وسام ولده الطفله هند رجب
طفله هند لها سبعه ايام مفقوده لحتى الان
ما فيش حركه لا من منظمات دوليه ولا من
منظمات حقوق انسان ولا من منظمات امم
متحده ولا من اي وكاله ولا من اي منظمه
ولا من اي حد مسؤول اصلا ولا حد عنده حي
ضمير انا من اول يوم ناشدت الضمير الامم
المتحده المنظمات الدوليه كل واحد عنده
ضمير ح لحد اليوم ما حدش لو انه طمني خبر
بسيط لو انه بنتي عايشه لو انه بنتي مصابه
بس بتتعالج لو انه الجيش ماخذها لو انه اي
اي خبر عن بنتي المفروض انتم مؤسسات دوليه
المفروض تكلموا الجيش المفروض تكلموا اكثر
من مؤسسه انكم تقدروا توصلوا للبنت مع
التنسيق اللي اعطونا اياه المفروض تحاسبوا
الجيش على التنسيق بحساب محكمه العدل
الدوليه طلعت انه اي مخالفات بتلاقوها من
الاحتلال ابعثوها على الايميل هذا طب هي
قضيه هند ليش ما انبعثت على الايميل ليش
ما انحطت لحتى الان في الارشيف ليش ما حد
يتعدل عليها محكمه العدل الدوليه وين
محكمه العدل الدوليه اللي بتحكي اي اي اده
جماعيه بدها تكون فيها لما يموتوا ثمانيه
في السياره زي كده وين هذه مش اباده
جماعيه ولا ولا حكيت لهم انتم ما في وقف
اطلاق نار حكيت لهم بيدوهم بس مش بالراحه
بدل ما تقتلوهم بال 400 اقتلوهم بال بالم
كل ثانيه كل ثانيه بنستنى في بنتي سواء
سمعنا صوت اسعاف بصير نحكي يمكن هند بسمع
صوت ناس جايه يمكن هند كل دبه كل اطلاق
نار كل صاروخ بينزل كل قذيفه بسمعها يمكن
جنب بنتي يمكن بنتي فيها يمكن للمسعفين
اللي مع بنتي يمكن حاول حد يخاطر خطرنا
الف مره نبعث حد يجيبها غير المسعفين اللي
بعثناهم ما حدش قدر يصل ما حدش ولا حد
قادر يصل المنطقه اللي هم فيها انا دارسه
علم النفسي وانا اكثر وده بحس في بنتي كل
لحظه ايش صار معها وكيف خافت بنتي انا
الدراسه اللي درستها يمكن ما اقدر اعالج
بنتي نفسيا لو اجتني بخير بنتي بدها جلسات
طويله غير الاصابه اللي هي فيها بدها علاج
وبدها دعم سنين لما تنسى اللي في و صار
تنساه بنتي لو صار معها كل الاطباء النفس
اللي بتحضر فيها لو صت بانتصار مع حبيبتي
اسدي لا سمح الله كيف بدي انا ا انقذها
منه غير المرض اللي هي فيه الامراض
النفسيه بتمرض اكثر من الامراض الجسديه
وكل المنظمات وحقوق الانسان بتعرف الكلام
هذا فالمفروض من سبعه ايام يعني من اول
يوم المفروض بنتي اجتني
فيه معنا الان من رفح رائد النمس المتحدث
باسم الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في غزه اهلا
بك سيد رائد بدايه الى اين وصلت جهودكم في
البحث عن الطفله هند والطاقم الاسعاف
التابع للهلال
الاحمر اهلا بكم لقد قامت جمعيه الهل
الاحمر الفلسطيني بالتواصل منذ بدء اختفاء
الطاقم وعدم القدره على الوصول اليه مع
جميع الجهات الدوليه والاميه من اجل معرفه
مصير هذا الطاقم ومعرف ايضا معرفه ايضا
مصير حياه الطفله هند ولكن حتى اللحظه لم
ترد اي معلومات من قبل يعني قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على اي من هذه المنظمات
ولا على جهودنا المتواصله من اجل معرفه
مصير المسعفين هل تعرضوا للقصف هل تعرضوا
للقتل للاصابه او حتى الاعتقال ومصير
الفتاه هدى ولكن للاسف حتى اللحظه ونحن
نقترب من اليوم السادس لم يصلنا اي شيء
بخصوص يعني التواصل يتم بين من ومن من هي
السلطات او ال
الجهات الاطراف الاسرائيليه التي يتم
التواصل معها وما هي
الردود يعني نحن لا نتواصل باي حال من
الاحوال بشكل مباشر مع دوله الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بل هناك وسطاء يعني ومن ضمنهم
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر والامم
المتحده والارتباط الفلسطيني وبالتالي نحن
لم نذخر جهدا بالمطلق في هذه الاتجاهات
جميعها ولحتى هذه اللحظه لم يصلنا اي رد
رسمي حول حاله هؤلاء المسعفين والطفله هدى
ايضا وكذلك لم تصلنا اي انباء ولا زال
الاتصال مقطوعا للاسف لكن اذا كان الاتصال
يتم عبر هذه المنظمات والمؤسسات الدوليه
ما الذي يحول دون استلام هذه الردود من
قبل الاحتلال يعني ما الرد الذي
ياتيكم لا ياتينا اي رد لان الرد بالاساس
معطل من الجانب الاسرائيلي واما بخصوص
سؤالك حول ما الذي يمنع فتجدر الاشاره
وكما تعلمون بان جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في هذا العدوان تخطى جميع الخطوط الحمراء
فيما يتعلق بحقوق الانسان وضروره تحييد
المدنيين والمسعفين والكوادر الصحيه عن
الحروب والمنازعات ولكن للاسف حتى
المنظمات الدوليه سقط من بينهم شهداء يعني
وهم تابعون لهذه المنظمات الامميه وتتعرض
مقارهم كما حدث مع مقرات الامم المتحده
الى القصف الاسرائيلي المتعمد وبالتالي لا
نتوقع ان يكون هناك ردود ايجابيه من قبل
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والذي قتل عدد من
مسعفين بالاساس
وبعد اتمام عمليات التنسيق اللازمه ورغم
ذلك قتلهم بدم بارده يعني رغم اننا لا
نحبذ الحديث حول هذا الموضوع لكن يعني ما
هي
الترجيحات مضى على
على غياب الطفله هند اسبوع وايضا
اختفى الفريق فريق الاسعاف التابع لهلال
الاحمر الذي وصل لاسعافه هل هناك من
فرضيات لديكم في الواقع
سيناريوهات الاستهدافات والاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه بحق طواقمنا متعدده يعني نحن
بعد هذه المده الطويله وبعد يعني ان بدانا
نشعر بالخطر الحقيقي على حياه هؤلاء
المسعفين والطفله هدى نحن نعلم جيدا بانهم
دخلوا منطقه عسكريه مغلقه ولكن هذا من
اعتبار الجانب الاسرائيلي اولا وثانيا
قمنا باجراء التنسيقات اللازمه من اجل
ضمان حمايه الطاقم الطبي واجلاء للطفله
بامان فبالتالي عندما يدخل هؤلاء المسعفين
في منطقه يعني تحت اشراف ومتابعه وتوغل
الجيش الاسرائيلي ف من المطلوب من الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو ان يحدد ما مصيرهم وبالتالي
في يعني مرمى نيرانو سواء كانوا تعرضوا
للقتل او الاصابه او حتى الاعتقال هذه
المعلومات يجب ان يجيب عنها الجيش
الاسرائيلي شكرا لك من رفح رائد النمس
المتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في
غزه